but in in the history of jackass there's
very like little that didn't
make it
somewhere somewhere yeah you know too
hot for tv or right you can kind of
count them on uh yeah i made a video and
i put it on youtube and it included some
of the things that i was like oh yeah
and this wasn't even allowed on tv and
then like with within a very short time
of me posting that video i received a
strike
from from youtube oh really yeah how
many strikes you get you had three
strikes and your channel is deleted
for is there like it's deleted for a
year or it's deleted it's deleted
forever but like
a strike puts you on probation for like
a certain amount of time and then the
strike will
will go away is that your only strike uh
i've had a three i had a warning and
then two strikes and the two strikes
went away but the warning stays i think
there was the hot sauce you can get it
at stevo.com on amazon
and uh because we put it up in my butt
and we really showed it like putting it
going in my butt and like me pooping
everywhere i was kind of like in
hindsight that was we're number three
yeah
we're number three on amazon right now
fyi yeah with your hot sauce yeah that's
great
and it caught me off guard i i put the
the best um
the best wake up pranks of jackass and
wild boys i thought we were like what a
fun video you know like whenever we have
the the mamba and we slap people in here
you were pure hell to wake up yeah you
woke up spitting and wanting to fight
yeah for sure the only time i was ever
tough is right when you wake me up yeah
yeah
then he calms down real quick but man he
comes out swinging and he jumped out
that window car
youtube didn't like the wake up pranks
because um it's like assaulting somebody
who's not consenting you know like
they're sleeping yeah they're sleeping
and they can't consent and you're
hitting them it's like an assault yeah
but i mean you're filming with us so
you're kind of consenting walking on the
ship but i understand that that was my
answer to the whole video i was like you
know i'm falling asleep on the very
irresponsible dude
you just want footage yeah you're
begging for it but but then and then i
got the strike for the one
and i showed it too box downstairs i i
was like all right that was just so
simple and dumb
could have been terrible oh it could
have been terrible knoxville got in a
[ __ ]
cardboard box with like a couple pillows
cardboard box they tape it up close and
then just knock it down the stairs end
over and don't don't don't don't don't
down all these cement stairs it was a
i don't know what i was thinking you
know i you know i'd been i just came off
a film right and the guys have been kind
of carrying the load and i hadn't been
able to do a lot of dangerous stuff
because i had been doing a film and then
i was like i got to get back into
the swing of things and get everyone's
respect in my mind that's why i was like
i had lost respect by doing this film so
i'm like i might as well come out
swinging
and
oh man i went it goes
skip skip and then it takes a big jump
and all the impact i absorbed on my
lower back it just slammed and that just
felt like pure hell i probably uh
started my lower back problems right
there that box downstairs and it was
like counterintuitive because you could
you gotta like just trust that you're in
the box he can't see you
right right right right no without it
being like uh a one long
take without any cuts like you know you
could have like i mean but nobody that's
nobody doubts us never nobody doubts us
and what was the the other okay there
there was uh i'm johnny knoxville and
i'm going to get hit by a car real soon
oh yeah that was from the big brother
video i think
yeah i'm sure like like can't put it on
youtube so people probably don't even
know about it yeah yeah the car like
when they see that
uh i don't know the buckle is sure if
they get there early they can see it but
what was your strategy with the car
because it hits you but then you like
end up on top of it like a cat through
the windshield over out of the roof the
car never slows down yeah
my oh my only thing i wanted to do was
get up on the hood
i didn't want to have my knees taken out
right yeah so i just tried to get up on
the hood and after that
that car was calling it's the most epic
[ __ ] shot he says i'm johnny
knoxville and i'm going to get hit by a
car real soon he's standing in the
middle of the road and showing up the
car just comes goes blowing right
through the frame he goes through the
windshield the car never stops and and
and later somebody asked you there was a
quote in big brother like what what were
you thinking standing there getting hit
by a car ed knoxville's answer was oh
well i wore two pairs of jeans so i'd be
safe
i i
i think i was totally
serious because i there i do have those
irrational ways to think that i'm safe i
remember when i was doing the python or
the anaconda ball pit i was like man
what i have to avoid here
is the snake biting my wrists and
severing my arteries so you put on that
i put a strip electrical tape around my
wrist
and in my head it was like
it was safe
but little did i know after i filmed
that bit the guy was like yeah one of
these anacondas took off someone's calf
muscle last week
but in my head that was that electrical
tape saved me it was your suit of armor
yeah yeah
yeah and and another one was when you
when you shot yourself with the
smith and wesson 38 caliber handgun
and you're wearing like a used 300
bulletproof vest you tucked some porno
magazines under it too yeah yeah yeah
yeah
thinking that was going to help it
wasn't it was a brand new vest but it
was the cheapest one they made
yeah i had some leg worlds up there and
whatever flint had whatever tremaine got
from flint just laying around and and
you said there was a shot
it was on camera like you're trying to
shoot yourself in porto magazines or
falling out of the bush
and then i've been over to pick it up
and so i'm stepping back in and i have
the gun pointed right at the camera
and it's just so
irresponsible wow
was it by design that you just put one
bullet in the gun so that you'd have the
suspenseful like click click
i put it wasn't by design just to put
one bullet in the gun but it
the the hole it going around i thought
it was like going to be one shot and
over but i didn't know anything about
guns so all the way around
but it helped yeah oh my god that
footage is intense
i i'm trying to think okay so another
one that was never allowed to see the
light of day
and it was genius was uh
the hardware store all right yeah yeah
tell us about that one
um
i put on a prison orange jumpsuit
and
get handcuffed and get my hair all dirty
and my face full of mud and i go in the
hardware store out of breath and i'm
like oh can you help me get these off
you know referring to the handcuffs you
have a hacksaw
oh yeah yeah yeah and we did that once
just
randomly right me spike jeff and
someone else and we didn't have any
camera hides or anything and but like it
got a huge reaction and like four or
five card loads of cops show up
and they all have their guns out and
spike and jeff are like what do we do do
we take off or
yeah
the best footage was that one of the
cops
pulls up
like it screams in the in the frame or
the footage is great the cop gets out of
their car but doesn't put it in parks so
this cop jumps out of the car and the
cards this cop car just continues and
crashes into a [ __ ]
like a telephone pole yeah
that was the second time we did it yeah
and the car that that oh the cops came
both times you did it yeah the cops came
both times we did it but it wasn't
covered because we didn't know what we
were getting into right and we didn't
know
but so it's poorly covered and we had to
do it again and the second time that's
when the cop didn't put her car in park
and it hit the telephone pole and by
that time i was on the ground with my
hands out here i'm like oh no we're
really in trouble now
she goes up to knoxville laying there
with her gun on him she says why aren't
you in jail right
and
god and she told me afterwards she goes
if you would have moved one little bit
or tried to get away i would put the
bullet in your ear so yeah so i knew
like when cops drew their guns just do
what they say yeah um and i asked her
afterwards i'm like is this the oddest
call you've ever been on she goes no i
had one guy
butt naked up the top of a palm tree and
he was on uh
like pcp or something and he slid all
the way down the palm tree balls and all
right
[Music]
he was straight to the middle hospital
yeah flawless
was there any punishment for the bit
like did you get i seem to recall that
there was a lawsuit that was settled for
like five thousand bucks uh our one of
our producers got arrested metha meta
got arrested
and i regretted that because
i was on the set i was the one who
should have gotten arrested but i really
didn't know how things worked and uh
but that was taken care of and uh why'd
she get arrested because she was her
name was on the the they're like who's
producing here who's producing here and
she's the one who stepped up yeah so one
of my favorite bits in it i'm not sure
if it's on the jackass but certainly the
big brother was uh when you ordered the
eggs and bacon
you scratched the bacon out and you put
[ __ ]
in there my sausage looks like poop
yeah that's a good bit yeah up until
then i'd been doing stunts and that was
the first prank i did and i don't know
why that was why i thought of that but
it's so good i'm trying to think of it
like there's really very little that
that that couldn't ever see the light of
day i got branded the heart over my
heart they said they wouldn't show
sizzling smoking flesh
so we said you could get branded but
yeah we said you could you could shoot
it but we didn't say anything about
airing footage of sizzling smoking flesh
what the [ __ ] do you think branding is
yeah yeah
the bomb lit didn't get aired yeah the
bomb vomit yeah with dave england uh
even though we're the re-shoot of it did
yeah yeah but the original was much
funnier because it was one of it's one
of those ideas where yeah it's like the
super glue
from jackass number two it was a rainy
day and what we'd wanted to shoot was we
could no longer shoot and right dave
england said hey i can eat all the
ingredients for an omelet and then puke
it up into a frying pan frying pan and
cook it and then
you you volunteered
to to eat it
it was just a [ __ ] show and florida the
room's hot yeah manny was there man he
loved that [ __ ] so much yeah
yeah dude